what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm wearing a 90s shirt - yep you're
the - to that sentence I definitely am
this is all in fitting I'm John I'm Greg
we are 90s children born in 1990 exactly
September 3rd June 2012 and camera
French is September 4th so it's his
birthday today happy birthday buddy
he's topper wart ear patron his video
request is from watchmojo.com top 10
movies the 1990s so of course for us
we're making sure to upload this for us
not for you yeah on your birthday it's
already your birthday now overshadowing
your birthday yeah sure so I'm supposed
to get a whole week no one else would
ever birthday
[Music]
this decade saw Hollywood turn to
independent studios Disney make a
comeback
and CGI advancements Disney was downhill
monetization issues do you mean all
these movies we chosen 10 movies per
decade based on their iconic status
critical acclaim I know it's gonna be on
here that I haven't seen yeah there it
is and the matrix that's 10 oh this
lists better this better be a great list
what is real his life just an elaborate
computer program at each other question
is radio it's not by the 1999 sci-fi
shooter that became one of the most
impressive science-fiction films to date
I'm watching this re-release on
Wednesday I've got a story to tell you
about how I didn't watch it yesterday we
follow protagonist neo as he explores
the synthetic world of The Matrix and
fights the oppressive evil that goes
along with it
look at him struggling aside from its
complicated plot this Wachowski brothers
masterwork is also visually stunning
this is not up to date with the
Wachowski
morning never not the Silence of the
Lambs you know he improvised uh it
brother Buffalo Bill on the loose
Rickey FBI agent Clarice Starling must
call on expert advice from captured
cannibal and experts psychologists
Hannibal Lecter to catch him if I help
you carries when we turns best to click
Coco I how do you think squid pro quo
mr. powers and earning the Silence of
the Lambs the big five Academy Awards
including the first-ever Best Picture
Oscar given to a horror film I do
I'm having an all in fact it's so good
by Club number eight wait what I
believed that was a real kid yeah yeah
we saw insomnia and what it was to be a
Gen X male in the 90s
[Music]
when our unnamed narrator finds solace
in the Bohemian Tyler Durden he's
finally able to live without regret and
start an underground records er named
called Fight Club the first rule of
Fight Club is you do not talk about
Fight Club divisive and controversial
upon its release Fight Club may not have
won any Oscars but it was one of the
most talked about movies of the decade
and the floppity Tanya very changed
[Music]
number seven toy store real the first
movie ever produced only computer
animated felony based around The
Adventures of toys that come to life
when no one's around we follow Woody and
Buzz Lightyear as they fight to be any
no pics are real ages knocked it out the
park number six
certainly aren't the film's your film
professor would choose Saving Private
Ryan will be on here next Spielberg came
out of his family-friendly comfort zone
to world war two movies though it was a
landing rod for controversy the film was
massively popular with both audiences
and critics
and just think Spielberg also released
the groundbreaking Jurassic Park that
same year
oh it's stressful part that year my bad
we're moving my bad a world of quotes
coming here like minded for scum who
don't have to be a genius to accomplish
great things
what determination can achieve and how
opportunity can always come a-knockin
Robertson Carlos event an Academy Award
winning performance telling a
bittersweet story that nabbed a slew of
other authors and watch this movie good
I think this is a weekend I'm watching
workers come it's on record now
what a segue just when you thought
Terminator flip couldn't get any cooler
Along Came t2 hasta LaVista
ba he sent them decade after the
original Barney's back only this time
it's to protect you see that like dark
blue lighting this movie has it or even
even here it's our fate design real sets
shot on film as I can remember I always
wanted to be a gangster a sauce movie in
the 6th or 7th grade gangster it's a
mortise or cz classic wrapped in
violence gangland activity and plenty of
based on the true story of Henry we play
mustard off you matter with him oh I
adore that even without side effects I
believe me we tried to steal every bit
of it while Scorsese's deliberate
directorial choices do elevate
Goodfellas it's the acting in this
perfectly cast film that makes it great
really my real Ray Liotta never work
with Scorsese in supporting work of
Robert De Niro great Oscar winner Joe
Pesci funny how funny
little pinch a loaf come back this is
all gone there it is remember to like
don't ruin it ever successfully not have
misery what jail watching him battle the
usual prison struggles and the despair
that will inevitably set in we see Andy
earned the respect of the guards the
prison warm and one inmate in particular
are you in for
okay with hope on his side Andy's fight
for Humanity is a truly uplifting story
that was nominated for seven Oscars here
are the good movies of the 90s for sure
hope your fiction will be number one it
will there were a lot of really good
night news movies huh
Reservoir Dogs would be an honorable
mention and one day Simba the Sun will
set or reverse but I'm gonna go my first
feel like it would be Pope you're mr.
Lebowski I'm the dude so that's what you
call me you know Pulp Fiction Quentin
Tarantino WatchMojo team was like watch
is that it I made a joke so he hid it in
one place you know we can hide something
his ass telling me interwoven stories of
multiple characters from boxer Butch to
hit man Vincent Jules
the film is incidentally based around a
mysterious glowing briefcase we have
visit
you know it's in that briefcase the
intent film from origins which is Kill
Bill three because it's gold do you
agree with our list it's your favorite
movie of the 90s stresser Park on them
is published every day be sure mentioned
[Music]
it got it you got co-opted with
Schindler's List
you know Jurassic Park Schindler's List
back to back you can't win with these
lists you know the only way to really
get away with a list like this even then
you can't really yeah if you really try
to specify upfront this is my opinion
even then you're gonna get crap but just
live a little bit more leeway for
someone to come in and defend you you
know yeah I feel like these lists are
designed for people to just go if it's
not my exact list I'm gonna argue with
you
and I like they show a tease at the
Saving Private Ryan opening beach battle
that 20-minute epic I just watch that
scene again like a few days ago just
that scene alone just this one yeah you
know like four went to bed and I slept
like a baby that scene is one of the
absolute most wonderfully directed
visceral and I can't think another war
movie that really makes you feel like
you're in the trenches that has just a
shocking instant violence that we're not
showing any footage of here
Wonder Woman you know yeah Wonder Woman
does it a little bit Chuck Nick Cage we
wouldn't wind stalkers oh wind talk yeah
if anybody needs to do a World War two
one I'm getting kind of Jurassic Park
Jurassic Park that's a war movie
Jurassic Park is a 90s movie yeah I
don't wanted this list come out 2014
five years ago I just feel like you know
Jurassic Park is still talked about to
this day yeah but I don't notice either
where what would you have swapped it out
for on the list that's what I Shawshank
and for us g4 again twice
the thing is when we list started my
initial thought was just like why to the
matrix at the back end and the more the
list went on the more I started to
understand at least that yeah oddly
enough because the matrix came at the
end so like the impact and the influence
of the matrix would probably be felt a
lot more throughout the 2000s so that's
one piece of this list I understand
unless this is definitely one of the
best films of the 90s however it's just
I mean I could kind of see why matrix
might be it even though t2 and matrix
are tied for my favorite movies of all
time it's less of a powerhouse emotional
experience I think than the other films
on this list mainly the emotional
experiences you feeling rewarded if you
understand it's one of the most
thought-provoking pieces ever that every
time you watch it you understand more
about it yeah so I think from an
intellectual experience and of course
being fascinated with the action in the
world all those like there are different
kinds of emotions but you know even like
you know t2 I don't think this is
thought-provoking why but it's
definitely got more emotion towards it
yeah I don't cry at the end of the
matrix but I cried the entity too you
know it kind of makes sense to me there
I mean I was just glad it's on the list
yeah man the Silence of the Lambs you
know they show Buffalo Bill oh yeah I
just feel bad for that guy because he's
the villain of the movie and he's so
excellent and he had to have the most
physically vulnerable moment movie has
been mocked and parodied and I used to
do it when I was a teenager good people
you know I love doing that moment you
know a moment I'm talking about I just
wish he got more credit for you know he
deserved he deserves more recognition
for that level of vulnerability where am
i Buffalo Bill fans out yeah join in the
comments man gosh like yeah people
parody the one line from that one scene
and stuff but is like I'd forgotten
element of the movie when it just gets
brought up in conversation which is
unfortunate yeah
is terribly scary no he's like the
unhinged serial killer whereas Hannibal
Lecter's in control
John I have a movie on this list that
you haven't seen I know
Fitz Club that's right never saw The
Fight Club although I know how it ends
thanks to high school homeroom class it
really doesn't I know yeah I just gotta
carve the three hours outdoors it's a
fast three hours this is this is
probably David Fincher's fastest paced
movie I've ever seen okay
there's so much going on and it spans a
good amount of time you know when we
were in school people keep telling me I
would love this movie and I think I'd be
what I thought you would have watched
him by now because I remember when we
were like what third grade whenever that
movie came out it was I clipped it out
of the news out the photo under Section
highlights
Turgenev rep it even got your haircut to
look like his I tried to I mean actual
open I drew you were channel is very odd
yes but really I really like Brad Pitt
yeah so cool but it was the coolest and
yeah and then I begged to go see the
movie and that was not gonna happen or
whatever time that everyone's good yeah
now weirdly as 29 year old males
you'd be like prep it's so cool is so
awesome he runs like trying to be cool
back in I didn't know anything about the
character contact I was the look was rad
younger it's harder to embrace it when
you're being made fun of
they made fun of matters like so many
fun making a joke yeah yeah that's our
contribution to the Fight Club
conversation relevant movie from what I
understand it is really cool and I think
Tyler Durden has got to be bred it's
sexy as character yeah and more so than
the vampire okay everyone talks about
cruise being sexy Brad Pitt is sexy in
general but even girls that I meet are
like you know I am NOT doing a fan of
Brad Pitt is that sexy but Fight Club
that's always has goes back to though
but
I feel like Brad Pitt easily falls into
the handsome like if he's sexy he might
be like a version of George Clooney sexy
but like yeah Fight Club is the one
where I think anybody could be like oh
my yeah
Toy Story now there's a sexy moving
there a sexiest of them all sexy is
definitely better than the matrix too
which is the toy store is a lot like The
Matrix it is actually mm-hmm what is
reality yeah Andy is the matrix it's
crazy to think how long like Toy Story
is a thing that's been there for most of
my life most of your life and it feels
so recent and yet there are four movies
deep it launched a whole studio that
eventually got absorbed by disk it's
like one of the first huge things of our
time to get absorbed by the Disney
machine looking at this footage it
immediately brought me back to my
childhood of popping and the VHS in the
living room and just watching this so
often so much on repeat I think it was a
little darker than I expected it
everything was SID yeah I wondered like
I saw Toy Story so many times when I was
a kid but it's honestly probably been
like 10 years since I've seen the movie
I always flashback to how I felt when I
was a child launching it and so I wonder
if like watching that dark stuff now
would be funny as opposed to does this
is kind of scary yeah yeah yeah I got
all any humor there flew right over my
head and when you're little enough to I
think the context kind of you forget
about it and so when the toys are coming
to life and they all look messed up and
they're encroaching on Sid in that
moment you're just in his shoes so
you're like oh god no you know when
woody is trying to get the toys across
from Andy's to rescue him and Buzz but
he's like using
Buzz's broken off arm yeah like to me
when I was a kid I feel like looking
back there's funny stuff about it I just
felt the peril like poor amputee is like
it's like and then he gets caught with
the arm like I just always felt so bad
and like this is making the situation
worse but I never found the funny
actually did this history is like a
really funny movie but I really did love
it well hey you were an empathetic child
even of her toys one of my dream
sketches
you know how when we do our sketches we
usually spoof a scene from a movie one
of my dream sketches is to have John
Hyde one of us dressed up as woody and
other one dress up as Buzz but shoot
like a really handheld dark dramatic
scene at a gas station see the whole
scene really critical I got revenge
isn't a concept we value in my place but
take it as serious as possible don't
play dramatic but really try to yeah I
think we'll start a whole new series of
sketches that way and then we can mash
up Toy Story and Schindler's List like
this list almost did I feel like this is
watch mojos most amusingly segwayed list
yes because a lot of unexpected segues
in this list in the Toy Story 2
Schindler mm-hmm that's where Liam
Neeson beats up a bunch of Nazis right
yeah out in the snow yeah you know it's
his least violent movie arguably but
it's most impactful I saw when I was a
kid I saw it in school we watched it in
like a comparative religions class or
something like that I love this
Schindler character man that moment
where he's just thinking about he saves
lives and then he's just thinking about
how much more he could've say or you can
say I've only seen this movie one time
since I was a kid and I only have like
flashes of a memory of these things but
that scene that's like the main thing I
remember and then like the ending when
they're summing it up with words and the
Schindler's hanging a little girl in the
Red Sea I remember that
oh yeah the proto Sin City doing the
colors over black and white guys down
low doesn't follow us in the start us
off so you could find out what I think a
Forrest Gump this weekend
Goodfellas now that's a great 90's movie
1990 Ray Liotta I don't think was
nominated for this and I believe De Niro
got Top Billing you know he's more
famous than [ __ ] he's clearly the
supporting character yeah ray liotta is
the lead other people give narrations in
the movie but he narrates most of that
it's mostly
the whole movie well you know Laura
learning browse on seventh grade I loved
it
Oh God Oh buddy it's weird it's this is
the kind of thing that like when
Tarantino tells 12-year olds to watch
Kill Bill this is how I feel good fells
like sure when you're like 12 13 go
watch Goodfellas man you know you watch
that walk any Goodfellas and casino and
funny enough back in the day I liked
casino better I've seen Goodfellas many
more times since though and I really
loved that I've always been curious for
a Ray Liotta I thought he might have
been casting the Irishman at one point
since it just seemed like Scorsese was
doing his greatest hits with that
casting and you know someone newcomers
as well like Ray Romano can't think of
anyone else all the rage but why was it
Ray Liotta in it man like Ray Liotta is
so good that scene when he finds out his
girlfriend Oh has been friggin hit by
mother-effing neighbor again that whole
shot I go looks at the rearview mirror
that crosses the story and the
characters following pants over it
similar the gun those guys are scared
thank you yeah what guy doesn't grow up
going I want to be that good of a
boyfriend some dude down in broad
daylight I'll never ever have the
opportunity and yeah Shawshank five
awesome star does that we both do a
joint Shawshank reaction what can you
really bring you to the table with
talking about Pulp Fiction and I thought
of something you know how nowadays a lot
of times these artistic directors have
to work within limitations and then when
they get a follow-up film it's like way
more unhinged yeah and you're like maybe
they should have reel them in yeah you
know that sometimes happens yes he'd
like surpassed whatever he did with
Reservoir Dogs ooh Pulp Fiction
Reservoir three this gigantic thing like
how many Direction can you say truly
have done that as time has gone on
unbreakable for M night Shyamalan some
people including myself consider that to
be his best movie ever but at the time
it wasn't - a lot of people's eyes us I
think there's an amazing film but you
know a lot of people walk out or can't
help but compare to get
out and what they like more about get
out I think it's kind of tort appeals
unbreakable in some ways I feel that
wait list like these especially maybe I
think about that passage of time and
what it does to the perception yeah but
with pulp fiction it was like
instantaneously you know some people
will still argue like Reservoir Dogs the
better film but easily call fiction
became the more iconic film like almost
right away yeah yeah well I think
there's there's a decent argument for
its placement at the top of this list
because I feel like it's a
quintessentially 90s movie and it really
is indicative of a wave of cinema that
was happening at the time indie scene
especially Tarantino Hannah Hannah and
kicking off like a whole movement of in
the cinema at the time it has spiraled
out of that and so yeah looking at all
these movies especially thinking about
these are great films of the 90s but I
think this one has definitely affected a
lot of sure the 90s as a decade of film
and beyond so you know like it made a
lot of sense to me even if it's not I
don't know if it's my favorite Tarantino
joint or not but I loved it every time I
watch it but I loved it anyway we're
missing Space Jam people Oh missing The
Mummy the lost in space movie our
missing Lana's film gray were missing
fools Russians sorry Matthew Perry in
Salma Hayek hmm three to tango Neve
Campbell worsen scream that's a real one
[ __ ] hissing damn they looked at this
list and they were like we can only put
one horror movie on here and it has to
be the Oscar well yeah but 90s horror
that would definitely be towards the
table the scream for sure scream in fact
scream has probably picked up so much
relevance over time because now we love
blatant meta [ __ ] well guys what's your
favorite movie from the 1990s you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell you check us on
patreon we do weekly Q&A a TV show
reaction stream along do you sync up
with the timecode
but some have reaction highlights
include a seat don't need to worry about
the sinking at all and camera French
what more is to say other than to
properly say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]